john hight nous est un artiste visuel et
un sculpteur ses oeuvres controversé
explore tous les thèmes de la religion
aux questions sociales
si john hight nous était un artiste du
sud du canada
il pourrait s'attendre à une couverture
médiatique et à la reconnaissance du
milieu artistique
c'est ce qu'obtiennent généralement les
artistes comme lui qui font tomber les
barrières et se font le miroir de la
société
mhadjou taille tout ne vient pas du sud
il est inuit et il vit dans la petite
communauté nautique de cap de recettes
au nunavut
les amateurs et les collectionneurs
d'art inuit passe bien souvent à côté du
travail de joe wright nous préférant les
images traditionnelles d'igloo et de
traîneaux à chiens aux oeuvres de tous
nous qui illustre la nouvelle réalité
sociale et environnementale du nord
canadien une de 2%
douze obus ou d'orties la popularité de
la reproduit par les inuits du nord
canadien remonte à l'époque où les
européens sont arrivés dans l'arctique
et qu'ils ont commencé à rapporter des
sculptures inuit en europe
aujourd'hui encore l'engouement pour ces
sculptures ne se dément pas les
collectionneurs demeure fasciné par ces
représentations de paysages apr ou d'une
faune et une flore inusité dans les
années 50 l'artiste canadien james
houston se rend à kiev dont 7 pour
enseigner aux inuit les techniques
d'impression sur place il fonde les
studios qui n'y ait à partir de 1959 les
gravures produite à quelques recettes
sont mises en circulation par le biais
d'une collection annuelle
les images de paysages arctiques ou de
la vie quotidienne inuit ont un succès
instantané
aujourd'hui encore les collectionneurs
du monde entier font la queue pour
mettre la main sur les éditions limitées
de ses gravures le jour de leur sortie
mais les choses changent dans le nord et
il en va de même pour l'art une nouvelle
génération d'artistes inuit s'intéresse
à représenter les changements
environnementaux et sociaux dans
l'arctique plutôt que les scènes de
nature ou d'igloo de la génération de
leurs grands parents
le seul problème avec ce nouvel art le
milieu artistique ne s'y intéresse
pratiquement pas
ce phénomène irrite la communauté
artistique inuit tout particulièrement à
quai d'orsay tu la capitale non-officiel
de l'arctique ningyo colocs tv est une
artiste de quête de recettes
ses oeuvres qui dépeignent des légendes
inuit où la faune arctique s'envole tout
mains des acheteurs dans les galeries
d'art du canada mais elle ne se gêne pas
pour explorer de plus en plus les
changements climatiques ou des thèmes
sociaux à travers son heure et même si
cela se vend moins bien rémunérés
l'élève tels que des jeunes on est nu la
musique la capitale du fogny symptômes
sa vaste feeling à 7 901 par le gène la
sorte d'astre à siewiller amicaux à bord
d'un cessna et des jackass mac mini
sa propre adresse tu t'y vie espère que
son art par viendra illustrer comment
les changements climatiques altère sa
propre vie et celle des habitants du
nord est de la commune il est à noter
que yann mendler la casse de la
starlette good as well as a rock
coldplay
oui c'est cocasse que nous joue à cache
vac vient elle aussi de clips de
recettes
elle est l'une des artistes canadiennes
et plus reconnu son oeuvre de 1960
ndao le hibou enchanté s'est vendu aux
enchères à plus de cinquante huit mille
dollars en 2001 un record pour une
estampe canadienne et bien qu'elle
préfère s'en tenir à l'imagerie qui l'a
rendue populaire
elle applaudit les artistes inuit qui
change de cap
mais tandis que la communauté artistique
de l'arctique aklane cette nouvelle
génération d'artistes
les acheteurs et les collectionneurs du
sud eux sont plus réticents à l'accepter
bilici dirige les studios qui n'y ait eu
que dans cette église qui mérite et le
maire de quête de recettes
il participe aussi à la gestion de la
coopérative eskimos de bafang ouest qui
exploite les studios kenya il croit que
les arts visuels sont une part vitale de
l'économie de clips de recettes et que
la mise en marché de cette nouvelle
imagerie va profiter à sa communauté
mais en attendant l'artiste du tas et où
nous lui maintient qu'il continuera à
créer son art à sa manière alors l'uqtr
vôtre
2010pour wallpapers présente en sauveur
on a dit tout le temps avec wally
todos tus maurienne
ce match